as a professional athlete  you want to do stuff that's  awe-inspiring hair-raising  death-defying dropping in three  two  one  our job is to perform when our lives are  on the line there's so much of it that's  mental there's a physical emotional and  even spiritual release  it feels pretty freaking next level  to be an elite adventure athlete you  have to push past the fear that stands  between you and your goal but if you get  that close you're going to have to  accept that sometimes things go wrong  [Music]  i started to feel the collapse  the current is moving so much  and i'm struggling to stay alive  pushing through the physical barriers  can be transformative  but pushing through the mental barriers  is  a transcendent experience  that sacrifice it's like giving so much  of everything that you are and hoping  that it's worth it it is necessary for  the people who do it you want  exploration you want adventure this is  it  sometimes the only way to find the edge  is to go over it